nouveau rassemblement de soutien au
peuple palestinien à paris comme celui
d'hier il a lieu depuis 15 heures place
de la république un rassemblement
autorisé par la préfecture de police
les précisions sur place de notre
reporter jonathan mois d'hab
plusieurs centaines de personnes
mobilisées ce jour place de la
république pour la deuxième journée
consécutive pour rendre hommage le site
aux martyrs de la résistance
palestinienne
deux jours après la signature d'un
cessez-le-feu entre israël et le hamas
sous l'égide de l'egypte cessez-le-feu a
mis fin aux jours de conflit qui ont
causé au moins de 148 morts côté
palestinien et 12 côté israélien une
trêve accueillie de façon mitigée par
les manifestants ici je vous propose de
les écouter le cessez-le-feu demain
s'ils veulent sera l île compte chine a
bombardé gaza pour des morts à gaza il
ya toujours des personnes qui sont
blessées
des personnes qui se font détruire leur
domicile ça fait très longtemps que
c'est la palestine et sur l'oppression
le monde entier regarde parfois
certaines périodes en bouche à d'autres
périodes on oublie et il est important
de continuer à se rassembler à rappeler
au monde que et surtout au peuple
palestinien qui sont pas seuls et qu'on
est tous derrière eux en fait une trêve
encore fragile les tensions sont
toujours palpables notamment à jérusalem
est où des heurts ont encore eu lieu ce
matin entre palestiniens et policiers
israéliens devant la mosquée al aqsa et
les observateurs sont aussi pendu à la
décision de la cour suprême israélienne
qui doit statuer sur le sort des quatre
familles qui doivent être expulsés du
quartier de cheikh jarrah situé à
jérusalem-est
cette cour suprême doit rendre sa
décision le 8 juin prochain